faudrait parler de vous qui êtes vous en
êtes vous êtes-vous timide oui
une fille comme vous marie josé nat qui
a une voix qui tombent les hommes
or avant roger dumas ce n'est pas votre
fiancée oui oui un fiancé définitif
[Musique]
pour nous c'est un défenseur maintenant
c'est évidemment la capitale d'où vient
ce choix le moyen de s'affirmer il
certaine indépendance vis à vis des
hommes
[Musique]
marisa parents vous avez très bien jouer
votre rôle vous avez écouté et
l'extension et un charme facile c'est
pas facile d'évoluer d'un homme on dit
pas il est mignon il est charmant il est
gracieux il est il pétille jamais jamais
en disant c'est toujours un grand acteur
ou un acteur ou une composition ou
quelque chose comme ça je me demande
pourquoi c'est toujours des filles à qui
on demande de jouer à ce petit jeu comme
ça je dévoile mon moi intérieur avec
tact et intelligence
soit beaucoup plus drôle si l'effet des
sacs des garçons doivent penser qu'une
femme vous aurez poser d'autres
questions quelles questions par exemple
mais une femme se serait adressé à
quelqu'un enfin vous vous adressez à une
femme
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
intel de mettre deux qualificatifs
devant derrière je m'étais scalise
qu'elle dit parce que les gens mais
disent oui mais les gens le mettent
moi je l'enlève la misogynie elle prend
une allure tout à fait autre elle et
elle est très très inquiétante est à mon
avis très très dangereuse parce que la
plupart du temps c'est elle prend le le
visage du paternalisme vous pensez
qu'ils pouvaient les filles et les
garçons de la même manière absolument
absolument
j'aimerais beaucoup que les âmes après a
tricoté par exemple qui se tricote leur
petit peu l'homme
[Musique]